invité de san roque a dit ce matin
laurence une aile ozier-lafontaine
nouveau bâtonnier de l'ordre des avocats
de la martinique depuis le 1er janvier
bonjour madame le bâtonnier
bonjour vous avez comme objectif de
construire l'avocat du 21e siècle
quelles seront ses points forts ses
caractéristiques alors l'avocat c'est
d'abord un professionnel qui a une
solide formation technique qui
accompagne un client qui est le
justiciable dans des domaines et plus
large qui soit au niveau tant
judiciaires que juridique
et puis l'avocat du 21e siècle à un défi
à relever c'est évoluer avec cette
société qui passe par le numérique et
donc qui nous amène à comprendre à
observer les besoins de nos clients
les attentes de nos clients d'accord
évolué avec cette société de plus en
plus rapide
de plus en plus rapide donc même si on a
une formation d'origine
il ne faut pas négliger la formation
professionnelle la formation tout au
long de la vie professionnelle formation
continue et la formation continue avec
les outils informatiques à la base les
outils qu'utilisent tous les acteurs de
cette de cette société vous avez aussi
dit vous dites vous dit également que
l'avocat est perçu différemment c'est à
dire alors c'est vrai que dans
l'inconscient populaire l'avocat est
celui le professionnel drapé de sa robe
noire de sa serviette qui va au tribunal
dans le prétoire plaidé s'affronter au
juge pour défendre son client
cet avocat la a tendance à je ne dirais
pas disparaître mais l'avocat
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas que ça l'avocat
c'est le conseil si celui qui accompagne
les partis c'est celui qui négocie qui
fait des transactions qui est un arbitre
qui est l'acteur de nouveaux modes de
résolution des conflits
donc qui accompagne le chef d'entreprise
qui accompagne un conseil
d'administration qui fait beaucoup de
juridique est ce qu il fait aussi quand
on voit les difficultés par exemple que
rencontre la prison du cause quand on
voit le nombre de de suicide la
surpopulation carcérale est ce que
l'avocat joue aussi un rôle de
psychologue ouvrant même d'assistante
sociale
sachez que l'avocat fait tout est là à
la base une formation juridique mais
dans la lah les confidences que lui font
les clients l'avocat est amené à faire
le psychologue le le médecin le
confident le des fois même
lamy parce que quand on ne sait pas à
qui parler à qui se confier à qui
raconter sans problème on leur raconte à
l'avocat quel regard avez-vous justement
sur ce que ce qui s'est passé ces
derniers jours on a vu le nombre de
suicides importants au centre
pénitentiaire de ducos
on parle beaucoup de leçons
pénitentiaire k-dow d'ailleurs été
épinglé pour une surpopulation
alors le paradoxe concernant le centre
pénitentiaire de ducos c'est que il y
avait eu des travaux d'amélioration
avant ces suicides
apparemment il y à une baisse des
personnes rentrant à ducos et pourtant
il y a eu ces suicides et beaucoup de
détenus se plaindre auprès de leur
avocat des conditions de détention et
donc ces suicides ont vraiment créé un
séisme auprès des personnes des
administrés de l'administration
pénitentiaire des personnes qui sont
concernées par
le parcours de détention et ça nous
amène à nous poser un certain nombre de
questions
le centre pénitentiaire de ducos a pour
objectif de fermer ces personnes qui ont
commis des exactions des délits des
crimes mais en même temps de les
préparer à la sortie et donc rien sur
ses traits à oui mais quand les
personnes se donnent la mort en prison
c'est qu'il y a un problème il ya une
difficulté et sait c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de porte de sortie c'est que le détenu
n'envisage pas un jour de retourner dans
cette société est donc aujourd'hui ça
permet de faire une véritable étude
analyse des conditions dans lesquelles
ces personnes sont détenues et en vue de
l'amélioration de cette situation vous
avez vous expliquer aussi que la tante
des clients changent également change en
croit alors vous savez que l'avocat est
une obligation de moyens c'est à dire
que on défend un dossier mme on s'expose
aussi un résultat qui n'est pas à la
hauteur de nos attentes nous percevons
que le client fut un temps accepté cet
aléas judiciaires
aujourd'hui voeux de la sécurité
judicieux guide hic quand un client
conclut un contrat il veut le faire
valider par l'avocat il veut avoir c'est
son pourcentage de réussite
il veut il attend de l'avocat un
véritable accompagnement pour avoir un
gain d'autant plus qu'aujourd'hui le
client accès internet il va aussi
s'informer sur six mois bien souvent
avant de venir voir l'avocat il vérifie
sur internet alors c'est un couteau à
deux tranchants cette vérification
parce que des fois il ya un risque qu'il
interprète mal l'information qu'il a sur
internet et il vaut mieux venir vérifier
auprès du professionnel qui est l'avocat
qui lui explique les subtilités la
technicité du dispositif légal ou de la
réglementation donc ça vous oblige donc
à modifier votre accompagnement du
client a complètement effacé issu d'une
observation de l'évolution de la société
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on s'adapte à
cette attente des clients qu'on soit
plus proche du client
conte
en prenne véritablement ses attentes et
surtout au niveau de la facturation que
l'on s'adapte aussi à ses moyens c'est à
dire qu'on arrive qu'on parvienne à
expliquer aux clients la valeur de notre
travail parce que c'est notre travail
c'est une véritable valeur mais à côté
qu'ils comprennent aussi que le résultat
il ne se fera pas d'un claquement de
doigts il ya toute une technicité des
arrières vous plaidez pour des avocats
plus plus ample mieux formés pourquoi ce
n'était pas le cas aujourd'hui
alors la formation continue elle existe
depuis 2004
ça veut dire qu'avant la formation
continue n'était pas prévu aujourd'hui
nous nous formons de plus en plus mais
c'est surtout le fait que le droit d' le
droit devenant de plus en plus complexes
de plus en plus techniques
cette formation est est incontournable
pour nous et donc cesser plus crucial
c'est de plus en plus crucial
aujourd'hui
autre point comment appréhendez-vous vos
relations avec la magistrature quand on
sait que vous présidez sites seront
était que les relations étaient un peu
tendu entre autres les bâtonniers la
masse de la magistrature
vous parlez de la relation entre le
bâtonnier et les magistrats juste raoui
magistrat bien sûr de tout oui de toute
façon cette relation elle est
obligatoire
après elle doit être respectueuse
cordiale parce que l'institution
judiciaire comprend les magistrats les
avocats les greffiers dont nous sommes
tous acteurs de cette institution
judiciaire
donc nous devons dans l'intérêt du
public
avoir la meilleure relation qui soit
mais certains parlent de justice à deux
vitesses beaucoup d'avocats on parle ils
disent ils vont jusqu'à dire que la
justice n'est pas l'image de la
population martiniquaise
alors c'est une impression qui a été
évoqué par l'un de mes prédécesseurs en
effet dans un article dans le france
antilles c'est son constat si son
interprétation de la süper réalité alors
moi je pense que
libre à lui de penser ça maintenant ce
n'est pas mon regard je pense que c'est
toujours un danger
c'est toujours dans un petit pays comme
le nôtre c'est toujours un risque que
qu'on était âpre est le comportement des
magistrats dans certaines affaires comme
un comportement qui dénote une justice à
deux vitesses maintenant à penser que
c'est une réalité qui qui est qui
existent et qui a accepté
je ne le crois pas et je pense qu'on
doit être très prudent à porter de tels
propos
il faut faire attention à ce que cette
impression ne concerne pas une affaire
ou une autre mais je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse considérer que ça soit une gérald
et une généralité
en fait je crois qu'il faut rester
attentif à cette situation il faut
rester vigilant sur ses dénonciations en
fait c'est que ces constats qui sont
dénoncés mais je pense que l'objectif
c'est toujours d'améliorer la situation
de telle sorte que ce risque là ne se
réalisent flop easy les relations entre
le bar où il imagine seront
obligatoirement obligatoire mentionné ce
n'est pas l'intérêt uniquement des
avocats dans leur travail ou uniquement
les magistrats dans leur mission
mais nous travaillons pour les
justiciables et il faut que les
justiciables y trouvent leur compte
il faut que les martiniquais est le
sentiment que la justice qui est rendue
en leur faveur
soit une justice de qualité et pour cela
il faut que les acteurs de l'institution
judiciaire que nous sommes se
comprennent se respecte et travaillent
ensemble
la division constitue le dit grand
problème de la martinique je suppose que
vous êtes vous que vous y êtes sensible
aussi serge letchimy a fait une
proposition de loi pour faciliter la
sortie de l'indivision successorale
concrètement qu'est ce que cette loi va
changer qu'est ce que cette loi va
permettre exactement il faut comprendre
que l'indivision est un problème majeur
au niveau de notre économie en outre mer
le
les difficultés de la sortie de
l'indivision qui sont dues
un dispositif légal technique compliqué
entraîne des conséquences au niveau du
du btp audi vous plus largement de
l'économie parce que vous avez du
foncier qui est immobilisé et qui
ralentit cette économie donc qui
constitue un frein est donc cette loi
qu'est ce qu'elle va changer au niveau
juridique elle va déjà prévoir un
dispositif dérogatoire à celui qui
existe dans le code civil et permettre
aux familles martiniquaises en tout cas
c'est le but de cette proposition doit
permettre aux familles martiniquaises de
liquider leur succession plus facilement
aujourd'hui on a une plus besoin du
consentement de tous les viseurs voilà
alors aujourd'hui on a une majorité des
deux tiers permettant de sortir de
l'indivision le l'objectif de cette
proposition est de réduire ce taux à
50,1 pour cent cette majorité à 50,1
pour cent des indivisaires alors d'abord
il faut aussi prévoir une régularisation
pendant un temps un temps limité des
successions qui sont aujourd'hui bloqués
et puis enfin il faut prévoir et je
tiens à le dire d'une évolution des
mentalités
madame le bâtonnier je vous remercie
excellente journée l écoute de nos
programmes
merci